the day in the life of a stay-at-home
husband sorry tough guys it's a day in
the life of a stay-at-home husband time
to check your misogyny at the door and
buckle up first thing I do is I make my
wife some coffee after making the bed
then I do my wife's laundry when
juggling your husbandly duties it's
essential to separate the lulus from the
dryer next I feed the dog because who
else is going to do it I start my
dominance overall I have left then I
make my wife some breakfast she likes
her eggs air fried with a rice cake and
peanut butter then I feed the plants
before I feed myself and I tidy up the
house once the house was clean my wife
took me out on the town followed it and
the patriarch mm-hmm